ja das ist ein Lösungsvorschlag ganz
genau also es ist so wir müssen uns
gesellschaftlich auch mal darüber klar
werden auch wenn das teilweise uns von
der Politik auch in von einigen Medien
anders suggeriert wird es ist nicht
normal dass jedes Jahr hunderttausende
Migranten ungesteuert in unserer
landströmen und hier Asylanträge stellen
wobei wir ja wissen dass eine ein viel
zu hohe Prozentzahl von diesem Menschen
keinerlei echte anerkannte Asylgründe
hat deswegen müssen wir mit dieser
Praxis aufräumen es ist äh eine ganz
simple Wahrheit dass der gemeinsame
Schengenraum von vornherein so gedacht
war dass man eine robust geschützte
EU-Außengrenze hat die aber
offensichtlich trotz der Milliarden die
frontext die Grenzschutzagentur bekommt
nicht so robust ist dass sie den Schutz
bietet dass wir uns den Luxus offener
Binnengrenzen im Verhältnis zu unseren
Freunden und Nachbarn die übrigens eine
große zivilisatorische Errungenschaft
sind dass wir diese haben dass das
diesen Schutz bietet deswegen sage ich
ganz klar Deutschland muss auch die
migrationsmagneten abstellen das heißt
zum Beispiel eben die Anreize
runterfahren cool Faktoren abschaffen
das heißt zum Beispiel mehr
Sachleistungen statt zum Beispiel
gezahlt das Geld an Asylbewerber da
könnte man ansetzen
da muss ich jetzt was tun deswegen Frau
Feser da wo es nötig ist sage ich
entlang der Schleuse Routen zum Beispiel
jetzt Grenzen schließen ganz einfach
Corona hat gezeigt dass es geht alles
andere schadet uns als Gesellschaft und
als Land das ist so nein wir müssen auch
mal differenzieren ja ich stimme dazu
für eine qualifizierte Zuwanderung die
brauchen Erträgen die brauchen wir sogar
mehr aber die Leute die wollen ja gar
nicht kommen weil wir natürlich mit die
höchste Steuer und Abgabenlast haben auf
der ganzen Welt auf der einen Seite
deswegen sind wir als Zuwanderungsland
einer der Gründe nicht besonders
attraktiv andererseits haben wir mit die
höchsten Sozialleistungen auf der Welt
für Zuwanderung und deswegen darf man
sich wundern das Ergebnis ist ganz
logisch dass wir eine Menge Zuwanderung
in die Sozialsysteme haben und viel zu
wenig qualifizierte Zuwanderung haben
und was man auch nicht vergessen darf
gucken Sie mal die letzten Umfragen da
steht die AFD zum Teil bei 17%. ich habe
das Gefühl die CDU hat kapituliert vor
AFD meine eigenen Partei muss ich auch
sagen scheint mir auch so hat
kapituliert vor der AFD den Grünen kann
egal sein den nimmt die AFD keine Wähler
Weg ja die freundlich vielleicht sogar
wenn die AFD insgeheime die stark ist
weil umso mehr wenn die Grünen dann für
Regierungen gebraucht ja und das kann
doch nicht sein dass wir einfach davor
kapitulieren und sagen ja das nimmt man
in Kauf vielleicht ins bald 20% oder
mehr AFD Wähler was auch ein Ergebnis
dieser Politik also ich finde weil sie
die Ukraine angesprochen haben jeder der
aus der Ukraine kommt dann sollten wir
mit offenen Armen aufnehmen meine
Position qualifizierte Zuwanderung auch
aber für die anderen da muss einfach mal
ein moderatorium sein da muss man sagen
das geht jetzt mal für ein paar Jahren
nicht auch wenn dafür eine
Grundgesetzänderung notwendig ist das
Asylrecht für das guten Gründen nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg ins Grundgesetz
eingebaut aber damit eigentlich wirklich
politisch Verfolgte damit den Aufnahme
gewährt werden kann heute wissen wir
dass es nur eine Minderheit der Asyl
Antragsteller ist die wirklich aus dem
Grund kommen und das war gar nicht für
diese Situation gedacht also müssen wir
da auch einen Änderungen ran und was
mich unglaublich nervt wir hören seit
Jahren immer die gleichen Sprüche von
Politikern ja wir müssen mehr abschieben
wir müssen mehr tun die Ampel hat eine
abschiebeoffensive gerade zu verkündet
ja von natürlich überhaupt nichts
geschehen ist und die die Leute die
können sich nicht mehr hören es nervt
sie irgendwann dass ich den ganzen Tag
erklärt bekommen warum was nicht geht
und es gibt da gute Gründe im Einzelnen
ich kenne die Gründe alle warum man
danach Leute nicht verabschieben kann
weil die Länder sind natürlich nicht
zurück haben wollen aber es ist auch gar
nicht möglich ein Politiker ist nicht
dafür gewählt jedes Jahr den WLAN zu
erklären was alles nicht geht
ich muss natürlich auch
durchgesetzt werden und ich ich komme
damit abfinden auch wenn man sagt es
geht nicht nein es muss natürlich gehen
und andere Staaten machen uns das vorher
natürlich kann man abschieben und das
muss man auch endlich schaffen aber
teuer
wir könnten wir haben rechts wir haben
vollziehbare äh vollziehbare
Entscheidungen wir könnten abschieben
dann müssen wir ganz ehrlich sein
vielfach ist natürlich die Angst vor der
gesellschaftlichen Debatte drüber da
wenn man jemanden abschickt natürlich
ist das mit der konsequenten robusten
Handlung des Staates verbunden aber wir
sind in Deutschland gar nicht mehr in
der Lage robustes Handeln überhaupt zu
thematisieren man wird das sofort in
eine Ecke gedrängt wenn man das fordert
haben
steht ja was glauben sie sind also
deine Adresse schon Forderungen die
Grenzen zu schließen die Innenminister
hat die Uhr Außengrenzen die sollen
geschützt gesichert werden muss man
jetzt soweit gehen auch die deutschen
Grenzen zu schließen eben gerade als
Sebastian hat gezeigt ist es möglich
also wir haben die bienengrenzen
aufgehoben und gesagt dafür müssen wir
die Außengrenzen schützen aber frontext
zunächst mal gar nicht in die Lage
versetzt das zu tun es ist ersten
Wahlperiode erst gelungen die
letztlich die Reserve die da eingesetzt
werden kann auf 10.000 zu erhöhen das
sind Positionen stellen die noch gar
nicht alle besetzt sind das heißt das
ist erst dem Aufbau und natürlich auch
immer wichtig dass man das
rechtsstaatlich einwandfrei macht also
es geht um ein grenzmanagement was auch
den Werten Europas entspricht und da ist
viel zu tun wir haben in der nächsten
Woche den neuen exekutiv Direktor der
Organisation auch im deutschen
Innenausschuss und wir werden ihn genau
dazu befragen was wir noch verbessern
können damit der außengrenzschutz auch
besser funktioniert als er das heute tut
wenn man Grenzen schließen will an der
nationalen Grenze dann muss man für alle
tun dann ist es auch für die Pendler
geschlossen dann ist es für die Familien
geschlossen dann ist es für die
Touristen geschlossen dann ist es für
die waren geschlossen und ehrlich gesagt
in so eine Welt lieber Herr Geißler
möchte ich nicht mehr zurück das heißt
deshalb halte ich nicht für eine kluge
Lösung das ist jetzt eine Ausnahme und
eine Notsituation so ist es auch
formuliert das wäre das gegenüber der
österreichischen Landesgrenze
installiert haben aber es ist unser
anliegt durch gute Zusammenarbeit mit
unseren europäischen Partnern auch
wieder dazu zu kommen dass die Grenzen
auch durchlässig sind und das ist für
uns in Europa eine Errungenschaft hinter
die wir nicht wieder zurückkommen
ich will nicht in so eine alte Welt
zurück ich will das doch auch nicht ich
finde es toll dass man es eine riesen
Errungenschaft dass wir einfach so rüber
fahren können nach Polen nach Dänemark
nach Frankreich zu unseren zu unserem
Nachbarn und Freunden das ist also enorm
wenn man sich die Geschichte Europas
ansieht dass das heutzutage so möglich
ist nur sie haben gesagt die Grenzen
werden quasi aufgehoben oder irgendwas
Weg das stimmt ja nicht es sind die die
gesicherten Grenzanlagen abgebaut worden
große Errungenschaft ist richtig aber es
sind ja nicht Grenzen plötzlich
gegenstandslos und wenn Menschen hier
illegal einreisen und dann am Ende in
unserem Transfer Sozialsystem hatten
dann ist das eine Überforderung in
dieser in dieser Masse von Menschen für
unsere Gesellschaft und dann ist eben
vorgesehen wenn die EU Außengrenze
diesen Schutz nicht bietet dass wir dann
an die Binnengrenzen dran müssen man
muss ja überall schließen es kommt ja
keine gibt ja keine große
migrationsbewegung aus Dänemark
Österreich
werden und ich sagen ja wir lassen
erstmal alle rein und irgendwann
versuchen
populistischer dieses Thema zu sprechen
sondern wir müssen sehen dass jemand der
an unsere Grenzen kommt und dort ein
Asylantrag stellt ja jemand ist der
nicht illegal einreißt sondern der einen
Rechtsanspruch den er hat laut unserer
Verfassung und den internationalen
Verträgen die wir unterschrieben haben
zur Geltung bringt und wenn dann die
Verfahren durch sind lernen wir das ist
immerhin gut über 50% sind die am Ende
auch Recht bekommen und wo klar ist dass
da ein schutzgrund da ist und jetzt
reden
Gesprächspartner mit dem Sie gerne
darüber reden können was er denn
eigentlich machen können damit wir da
möglicherweise auf 80 auf 90 auf 100%
kommen und dass wir es schaffen dass
diejenigen die hier in der Sackgasse
landen und die dann aber auch trotzdem
bleiben weil wir sie jahrelang nicht
schaffen wieder in ihre Länder zurück zu
bekommen was wir an der Stelle
verbessern können und da kann ich Ihnen
ein paar Dinge nennen auch die die
Regierung schon gemacht hat wir haben
hier schon die Gesetze verändert
Beschleunigung bei den Verfahren
Verlängerung von Abschiebehaft wir haben
einen Sonderbeauftragten für
migrationserabkommen installiert wir
sind auf europäischer Ebene dabei zu
grenzverfahren zu kommen damit schneller
auch an den Außengrenzen bereits
entschieden und geschaut werden kann wer
hier auf welchem Weg auch nach Europa
kommen kann und vor allem und das ist
dann fast schon Überleitung zu dem Thema
was ich mitgebracht habe werden wir
diese irreguläre Migration dadurch
abmildern können dass wir den Menschen
legale Wege öffnen für diejenigen die
sich qualifizieren und die hier auf
unserem
Arbeitszimmer beitragen können
wir sehr Ansätze ganz gut gefunden wobei
mir die Ergebnisse hierbei noch fehlen
und es ist auch bei weitem nicht nicht
ausreichend wenn sie sehen ja dass sich
an den Zahlen nicht verändert wir haben
die Situation massiv übrigens
nicht die nationalen Grenzen schließen
du blöderweise stimmt
natürlich funktioniert das Ganze Regime
an der europäischen Außengrenze nicht
und deswegen ist eigentlich der erste
Ansatzpunkt zweitens es muss natürlich
natürlich auch der wirtschaftliche
pulfaktor weg wenn ich in Frankreich
bereits in Schutz quasi quasi in Schutz
bin als Kriegsflüchtling dann darf es
keine wirtschaftlichen Anreiz geben nach
Deutschland zu kommen und da braucht es
natürlich auch europäische Lösungen
darüber wie viel bekommt jemand oder
welche Leistungen bekommt jemand kann
man natürlich von mir aus nach Kaufkraft
nach Kaufkraft noch mehr Staffeln aber
klar ist es gibt in europäische
pulfaktoren die dazu führen dass nur
wenige Staaten die ganz ganz große Last
auch ein Kriegsflüchtlingen tragen und
bei denen die aus anderen Länder kommen
in meinem Landkreis übrigens
mittlerweile 40%, die eben nicht aus der
Ukraine zu uns kommen sondern
hauptsächlich nigeria ist dazu zu nennen
Türkei Afghanistan Jemen äh diese
Staaten schon darauf da müssen wir
natürlich viel viel konsequenter sein
jetzt sagen Sie natürlich klar der
Anspruch dass sein Verfahren geprüft
wird da bin ich ihrer Meinung aber
keinen Anspruch dass er während dieser
Prüfung bereits verteilt wird auf die
Kommunen und natürlich haben wir dann
Anreiz wenn ich kommen kann wenn völlig
unbegründeten Antrag stellen kann was er
bei fast 50% gerade selber gesagt haben
der Fall ist wenn es dann aber dazu
führt dass ich in einer Gemeinde bleiben
darf dass ich dann auch sofort relativ
schnell auch arbeiten darf zum deutschen
Mindestlohn der natürlich ein Anreiz ist
weniger als Nigeria kommt ist doch
logisch ist kein Vorwurf an die Person
als Nigeria sondern weil die Gott sei
Dank logisch denken kann die Person sagt
die das nehme ich mit das ist ja klar
deswegen gibt es hier pull-faktoren und
genau diese müssen wir natürlich
ausschalten und wir können nicht immer
so tun als gibt es keine Faktoren
eigentlich habe ich immer das Gefühl
dass bei großen Teilen ihrer Partei und
der vorgehalten haben bei den äh bei
aller größten Teilen ihrer Partei und
bei meiner Partei hier Einstimmigkeit
herstellen das Gefühl dass die Grünen
hier äh die Moral definieren und er sich
dann jeder ausrichten soll das finde ich
sehr sehr bemerkenswert weil in einem
Rechtsstaat eigentlich das Parlament
definiert was rechtschreiblich gelten
soll und nicht und da gibt's eigentlich
Regeln die defacto heute nicht
eingehalten werden bei fast die Hälfte
aller Anträge schlicht und ergreifen
nicht vom sich keiner sagen eigentlich
auch die SPD verliert ja nicht unlässig
wieder an die AFD genau wie auch die CDU
wie auf meiner eigenen Partei jetzt sind
wir in Umfragen bei 17 Prozent
vielleicht sind wir bald bei 20%. sie
sagen ja das ein oder andere müssen wir
ändern aber vieles geht nicht zu ändern
ja und dann muss man das halt so
akzeptieren und für mich ist es eine
Kapitulation auch vor dieser Situation
machen sich da keine Sorgen ich habe es
nicht von akzeptieren gesprochen sondern
es gibt eine von der Arbeit in den
Herkunftsländern über die Situation in
den Transitländern wo die Menschen
stranden über die Frage der europäischen
Zusammenarbeit bis zu dem was wir an den
nationalen Grenzen tun können und mit
unseren Verfahren auch die wir deutlich
beschleunigen und verbessern müssen
weiterhin tun kann gibt es ein Bündel an
Maßnahmen was wir sehr viel beherzter
jetzt innerhalb wir müssen als es in der
Vergangenheit der Fall ist also das ist
eine Riesenaufgabe und ich stimme Ihnen
in einer Sache zu und in der anderen
widersprechen ist wenn sie sagen am
besten wäre würden die Leute erst
verteilen wenn sie wirklichen geprüften
und positiven Bescheid haben das wäre
gut das würde gehen wenn wir sagen die
die Verfahren dauernd drei Monate
innerhalb der drei Monate sind die
Menschen in sogenannten ankunftszentren
wo sie gut versorgt sind wo sie auch
Betreuung haben wo
gesundheitssicherheitscheck so all diese
Sachen stattfinden da haben sie dann
auch eine unabhängige verfahrensberatung
haben alle Informationen die Sie
brauchen und am Ende dieser Zeit fängt
dann die Verteilung auf die geflüchteten
an das ist etwas was wir in einem
Normalzustand erreichen müssen
Normalzustand heißt nicht die Zahlen die
wir im Moment haben sondern wir sind im
Moment in einer Zeit die uns leider und
es sind nun leider aber auch Gründe ob
das nun Erdbeben Türkei Syrien ist ob es
Afghanistan ist ob sie die Länder diese
genannt haben das fällt nicht vom Himmel
dass Menschen aber eine Sache will ich
gerne noch widersprechen weil ich mag
diese Formulierung von der Einwanderung
die Sozialsysteme nicht weil wir auch
wissen wenn wir das über Generationen
sehen haben wir am Ende tatsächlich als
Gesellschaft einen Nutzen von
Zuwanderung über alle Kategorien hinweg
das ist also eindeutig eindeutig
beschrieben
völlig wichtig zu sagen Arbeit Sprache
Bildung Begegnung von Anfang an weil die
Menschen ja gerade kein Verständnis
dafür haben dass Menschen monatelang
irgendwo rumlungern und sie in
Anführungszeichen auf der Tasche liegen
vielleicht auf dumme Gedanken kommen
anstatt hier auch gleich zum Wohlstand
mit beizutragen
weil ich in dem Fall wirklich eben
gerade die interessante Frage nämlich
von Heinzelmann macht ihnen das Angst
macht ihnen diese Entwicklung gerade
Sorge gehen wir im schnellen Tempo voran
kann ich auf alle drei Fragen antworten
nein das macht mir keine Angst und ja
wir müssen da mehr tun also das Tempo
bisschen beschleunigen das Tempo müssen
wir deutlich beschleunigen auf jeden
Fall wurden sie abgezockt oder
reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall